let's go to our next caller from the
to14 area code caller from to14 welcome
introduce yourself what's going on hey
David my name is Brody I'm calling from
Dallas can you hear me okay yeah go
ahead Brody hey so I was calling
regarding the earlier statement in the
show this week about [ __ ] O'Rourke and
Ted Cruz's kind of getting heckled by
the protesters at the restaurant they
don't discuss yep yeah as a disclosure I
do volunteer for the campaign here which
I wasn't see which campaign okay Beta
Beta campaign um so I just wanted to see
if you thought about this argument in
terms of pragmatism that if we have art
of this perception of the left
creating protests and people
unnecessarily associating with you know
any kind of activism with an Tifa is it
tragg Matic to sort of look at the okay
is this going to help us get turnout and
convince independence or is this a
bigger risk of shaming them what can
they both exist you know in a in a
cohesive nature I don't know if I
totally understand dude this does
heckling a politician achieve the
political ends that we want is that sort
of what you're asking
yeah yeah that's the question I'm asking
is that are we a lien ating people by
doing that activity or is it worth
actually protesting in that manner I
don't think that there is one set answer
to that and I think here's where maybe
the confusion is the people who have
sort of disagreed with my take that
listen if you only protest in the ways
that the people in power approve you
will get nothing done right they have
pushed back right I said something
similar to what you're saying which is
but hold on a second if people who
aren't engaged see people yelling at Ted
Cruz at a restaurant are they going to
go out and vote for Beto or work number
one I don't know that that was the point
of the protest I thought the point of
the protest was related to Ted Cruz's
role in the confirmation of accused
serial sex assault or Brett Kavanaugh
like I didn't I didn't even think that
there was it was ostensibly to get
people to vote for Beto or work yeah I
suppose that's that's the case and I
guess what I'm looking at is you know in
terms
encouraging that protest with his family
there yeah I just worry that were in
some cases enabling that sort of
ideation although it is important when
we have this issue going on it's a
little concerning because I'm wondering
how that's going to affect voters if you
think it's going to affect voters
yeah well listen i mean the the phrase
with his family there it's like i'm very
clear that you shouldn't go to the
school of ted cruz's kids and protest
them right what ted cruz was out to
dinner and he had his adult wife with
him and she wasn't being protested it
was about Ted Cruz and his role in in
the Brett Kavanaugh confirmation so I
don't even know that it's relevant to
say with his family there I mean it's
like the the guy's an adult his wife's
an adult she's choosing to be with him
and the guy is a controversial figure
yeah I think he was the most important
thing on this and I get when people say
when I see on TV people yelling at Ted
Cruz in a restaurant I don't know what
it like that's certainly not going to
change what Ted Cruz is going to do
right he doesn't care he's not gonna
change his mind because people heckle
him I think we have to take a step back
and think about it more broadly which is
the ways in which people are allowed or
encouraged to protest continues to be
narrowed further and further what that
leads to is a decreased awareness from
the population that some of the stuff
that our elected leaders are doing is
controversial so while I agree with you
that merely seeing people heckling Ted
Cruz at an expensive restaurant might
not get them to vote in a particular way
in the Texas Senate election the big
picture of it is that more protesting
more civil disobedience more making
noise about the fact that a lot of
people aren't happy with what our
elected leaders are doing in total is
going to raise awareness of the fact
that controversial things are being done
that aren't good for us and hopefully
from that the activism would come I
don't know that that's what would happen
for a fact but that's kind of right on
outlook on the entire thing cool yeah I
really appreciate you you know Clara
flike talking about that because I think
your points pretty valid there and I
kind of maybe misheard it or just from a
bias kind of misread it and I get to say
I don't know packing area but shout out
said producer Pat and producer Matt all
right yes
shout out so we'll be distributed and
noted in evaluation forms Brodie thank
you
appreciate it I look forward to hearing
from you again we will take a quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because we are taking more calls if
you're holding don't hang up we will get
to more people right after the break